well brian a day after flash floods
destroyed parts of overton and logandale
people are really trying to do their
best to try and assess the damage and
rebuild
and that includes a local dog rescue
that lost nearly everything
now they're asking southern nevada for
help as they try to get back on their
feet
sasha loftis has our story
everyone out here in overton as a flood
swept through the town on tuesday
leaving destruction in its wake
now a local dog rescue and training
center is asking for the community's
help
to rebuild it was
wow this is bad this is bad kevin
martinez describes the moment he
discovered his property
and the entire town of overton
underwater the entire street was flooded
and
dams were breaking and railroad ties
were coming down the street
and all that was going through my head
is my dogs
my poor dogs he runs citizen k-9 club a
non-profit that trains
rescue dogs to work in personal
protection or security fields
i'm losing this training center where i
train the dogs i'm losing the housing
center where i house the dogs
but tuesday's flood destroyed the entire
facility
the dogs are ok but kevin is now out of
options we're kind of back to the
drawing board with the
what we're going to do as far as housing
the dogs and what's next for them so
he's asking southern nevada for help
as he gets ready to rebuild it's been
awesome to watch this community come
together in this time
he hopes the kindness he's seen can
extend to the dogs he knows
and loves this is a traumatic experience
that they went through
now if you'd like to help kevin and the
rescue dogs affected here we do have a
link to a fundraiser
on our website that's 8newsnow.com
reporting in overton sasha loftis
8 news now